[Music]
[Applause]
justin bieber breaks down in tears on
stage
the biebs can't hold back his emotions
amid the devastating tragedies around
the world during his justice tour stop
in mexico the sorry singer takes a
moment to address the crowd just days
after the texas school shooting that
left 19 kids and two adults dead i just
want you guys to know this tour is about
unity
[Applause]
[Music]
that everybody is equal
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
and a lot of racial injustice
[Music]
[Applause]
we get to stand together and unite
and celebrate amongst one another
because we're all the same
justin shared his tearful moment on
instagram and explained in the caption
quote tears fill my eyes with hope for
humanity i've been
having a lot of cries lately
but this isn't the first time justin's
gotten choked up recently last month
justin and his team came together
backstage in buffalo new york just hours
after a gunman opened fire at a grocery
store in a racially motivated shooting
you guys probably heard what happened
pretty horrible stuff but um
i'm looking forward to tonight looking
forward to getting on that stage and
doing what we do best and having a good
time and bringing joy to the city it's
much needed
later on stage justin led a moment of
silence for the fallen victims
you know as we know
there's been tragedy in the city
but what we're going to do tonight
is we're going to honor those people
and i would love
if we could just take a moment of
silence
that would mean a lot to me
so we can start
right now
it comes as no surprise that justin is
using his platform for good he told et
back in 2015 during his purpose tour
that it's all a part of his life's
mission
purpose is such an important
thing in life and
i just wanted to use my platform to tell
people that
you